this morning newlyweds from Indianapolis
are recovering at a Florida hospital
after a near-death experience on their
honeymoon
the couple was hiking on a dormant
volcano on the Caribbean island of st.
Kitts when the husband plunged more than
50 feet his wife was the only person
there to rescue him here's Jamie yuccas
the tropical island of st. Kitts seemed
like the perfect choice for a honeymoon
to clay and a kami Chastain the
Indianapolis couple was hiking a dormant
volcano clay found a rope leading down
into the crater as he headed in his wife
stayed up top I was just holding on to
the ropes kind of walking down backwards
like you would a ladder the next thing I
notice I'm sitting on the ground with my
leg head between my knees and vomiting
up blood and there's blood all down my
shirt I think that a rope snapped and I
fell but we're not entirely certain
because I don't remember falling it off
when his wife reached him clay had no
idea where he was he was incredibly
lethargic and he had no sense of balance
so he was kind of just like an
intoxicated person basically it's like
the best way to describe it a kami had a
push pull and coax her husband out of
the volcano and down the mountain and I
was completely freaked out because I
knew we were entirely alone after nearly
four hours a kami was finally able to
get cell service and call for help I
think was just by God's grace that we
were able to make it all the way down or
make people to make it to safety that I
was implicate ambulance there clay
sustained a serious head injury
the couple's family raised nearly 36
thousand dollars to transport clay back
to a hospital in the States
and he had a fracture at the base of the
skull in the temporal bone this is a
very serious injury fortunately the
fracture was where the bones did not
actually become this place they stayed
together
doctors expect he'll make a full
recovery and the newly would say when
they return to Indianapolis they'll
enjoy the rest of their honeymoon on the
couch for CBS this morning Saturday
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles performing your
wifely duties Wow
she's not going to
ever live this down for better or worse
right away you go